Alison, are you being a Dunderhead?
Aye always, always.
In Dunderhead News.
Hello everyone and welcome to the very 169th episode of Octothorpe, a podcast for science fiction and science fiction fandom.
Which is giving assistance to an age-appropriate woman by the road on the 24th of September 2026.
I'm John Coxon.
I'm Alison Scott.
And I'm Liz Batty.
And we have a lot of letters of comment.
We cannot do all of them.
Yeah, because we didn't read any of your letters of comment out for several weeks.
We heard from Chris Garcia, Chris Garcia, and Chris Garcia.
Firstly, Chris calls me a fool for not um picking best novel first.
Chris also says we need a swim headphone chat theme song.
And Chris sent us a picture that Bella took, which is some Octhorpe fan art.
And thank you very much for doing those things, Chris.
Oh, and Chris's name is now promo code Chris.
Why?
Oh god, did I not read my email?
No no no, this is this is because on the uh a like on Discord enforced basically it would when you signed in it would yet set you up with your badge name.
Which in many cases is not the same name you would use online, so people trying to change it.
But Chris had obviously managed to write in somehow in his registration form that his preferred badge name was promo code Chris.
So that's his name now.
And it also came up uh on the business meeting.
So every time Jesse called on him to speak, uh they were like promo code Chris and
It's just it's very good.
It's not every day that you get a completely new nickname like well into your forties.
It's good.
I I think it I think it is a sensible policy to say okay your badge name on the Discord should be the same as your badge name at the con.
then you know if you're there in person and you're being naughty on Discord you can be pulled up for it.
But it did lead to some comedy things.
I dunno, it seemed fairly obvious when I registered which box is where I put my name, but Ha ha ha Hey, hey, whoa, hey, oh
Shots fired, Liz.
Fight and talk, sorry.
Chris write in.
We heard from Andrew January
And he was curious because as you may have noticed in the Hugo Draft episode, we were maybe a little bit sweary, but that's only because I kept stealing John's picks and John kept stealing my picks and we got a little bit swary.
And this made Anu January interested in whether that was the first time we had said some words.
I don't know how s I don't know how sweary I want to be.
I don't want to turn this into an absolute swear bomb, but he basically went and looked through our transcripts and pulled out every time we had used one of a variety of swear words.
and made us a nice plot of our sweariness.
Um pretty good.
Uh our number one swear word is fuck.
But shit is doing
It's quite close behind, but this is because and there is a spike in the graph, which I had to go and look up, and it's when Alison like dropped a cup of tea on her laptop and just went ch chit chit chit chit chit chit chit chit.
Coffee.
But yes.
Hopefully that won't transcribe properly because it will also inflate our our swearing account.
But yes, this is the first the first time I think anyone has gone as far as to make a graph of our swearing.
Um so thank you very much, Andrew.
And
Can we put the plot in the show notes?
We can link to it somewhere and put it in?
We can link to it probably.
I haven't seen this plot because I believe the plot was somewhere else.
Oh no it's not, it's here
It is in my email.
I don't know why I didn't it's like it does surprise me that we say beep more often than we say bollocks, say
Hmm.
Oh dear.
I feel like if Apple saw this link we would be put into adult podcast hell.
I think we would, and I'm not sure how many trigger it, that's why I was trying to be slightly circumspect, but not really that circumspect.
Alright.
But we could put a link in the in the show notes.
We will put a link somewhere.
We'll try to be less swary because we are a family podcast.
And if you're in our family, then all these words got said a great deal.
So you know.
I might have been a bad mother.
I mean I know there's a podcast that will basically if there's swear words they will give a little message at the start say, you know, if you're in the car with your kids you might want to turn this one off.
We would have to have that on all of them, I think.
Yeah.
But we're not sweary really, we're just British.
That's probably the episode title.
Ed Morland wrote in to tell us that there's also twenty thirty-eight Tycoons of the Asteroid Belt if you want other eighteen XX games in space.
And then the question is, Ed, when are we when are we going to play an 18XX game?
But Ed doesn't like roll and rights I've discovered and Ed is there for a wrongin'.
Ed doesn't like a lot of games.
Ed is very picky.
Ed, Ed, Ed I think he just plays a lot of games.
You should you should be appreciative of his pearls of wisdom.
I am appreciative of his pearls of wisdom.
But rolling rights are great.
Yeah, I mean that's d this is the thing.
I'm appreciated of the pearls of wisdom, but sometimes he's just flat wrong.
Ed I think as a podcast we can be in favour of roll and rights.
That's fine.
Uh the reason I bring this up is because I read an article
um about a new uh Lord of the Rings roll and right where um everyone at the table is playing the fellowship against the person on the left and they're playing the forces of evil against the person on their right and that sounds incredibly interesting to me.
And uh I thought it sounded cool, but Ed's like, no, only trick taking Lord of the Rings games are valid, all other Lord of the Rings games are bad.
Okay.
Fine.
What about pandemic style Lord of the Rings games?
Ed doesn't like pandemic style games.
Uh okay.
Oh, okay.
Well, you know, he could just be wrong, you know.
That's where I started, and then you got all annoyed at me.
Well you know, matters of personal taste and everything.
And I play a lot of games and I have strong opinions on games but then probably different from Ed's.
I do like Rolland Wright's and pandemic style games.
In the last episode, I claimed that LA Con were using control for registration software, and I was wrong because that's the one used by 2025, 2027, and 2028, but not 2026.
In my defense, I'm not exactly paying massive attention when I log on to convention software if it works.
So basically, you should take this as a compliment.
That I don't notice what the software is.
No.
But we got a letter from Henry Balin uh saying I think we need to think about convention software names and pointing out we have currently CONGLAR, Concourse, Control, and Conreg.
um that all the different bits of the convention as well as the ones that name things like Zambia, which I think we've discussed before, doesn't really tell you it's about program planning, but is
Slightly more unique, on the hand, not very googlable.
Uh Planarama is program planning software, which I think does give you an idea of what it does.
And the Hugo nomination of voting software is called Nomnom, which I think is great.
So yeah.
Yeah, and turn out to turn no notes.
So basically if you're writing new con software, maybe don't start it with the word con and also make it
Funny 'cause then I'll remember.
Yeah, I think that's fair.
Andrew January needs to write in because when he called the Watson bot Watson, there was a funny reason for it, and I cannot remember what the funny reason is.
Uh Watson is the thing that posts all the links to Watson next on the Yes.
On the con?
Yeah.
Oh, it's because it's Watson.
So he called it Watson.
Um That that's fine.
That was good.
I like that.
More of that sort of thing.
Kevin Anderson wrote to us to say if we're ever in Atlanta, he would happily make us a cocktail.
And I for one and up for that when I'm in Atlanta, I don't know when I'm gonna be in Atlanta
Kevin, it seems very hot and very southern for me.
But it's not impossible.
And I will definitely take you up on your offer if we're there.
I was gonna say that if I am in Atlanta, then I will definitely want a cocktail because it will be so hot I will want to die
I mean they must have winter in Atlanta, right?
I think they do.
Although the impression I get is that seasons are less less of a thing in Southern America than they are in Britain.
when I'm sprang your first move here, she was like, what is going on?
Why does the weather change so much between winter and summer?
And that is a concept called seasons.
Uh no, I think uh I it kinda depends where you are in America, 'cause there are plenty of places where the season changes a great deal between winter and summer, like all of the middle bit.
I said Southern America.
Oh yeah.
She was from a place called California.
I don't mean Southern America politically, I mean Southern America as in towards the South.
While I lived in Texas, I was like in Houston, which is quite a hot place, and it snowed once while we were there and and the entire there was about quarter of an inch of snow and the whole of Houston ground to a halt for several days.
Because they had no concept of this.
They were like, What is this strange stuff falling from the sky?
To be fair, there have been times when it snowed in the UK, which happens on a fairly regular basis and everything just grinds to hold.
So Yeah well
W it was less snow than that.
It was the amount of snow which if you got to London you go, ooh, it's sleeting a bit.
Kevin made me a cocktail at a party in Los Angeles.
Uh he made me a Caesar.
um which is it's a Canadian drink which is reminiscent of but not the same as a Bloody Mary and it is
vodka clamato hot sauce and oorcus instead of instead of tomato juice and clamato is a mix of tomato juice and clam broth
And I liked my Caesar very much.
Hispania did not like her Caesar very much, and therefore I liked my second Caesar very much.
Thank you, Kevin.
Kevin was an absolute trooper.
He basically just did bartending for Edmonton for like three and a half hours straight and then sticked around to tidy up and I think
That is above and beyond the Call of Duty, and he looked damn good doing it.
I understand he's very tall.
Ooh, gross
Yeah, I don't like Bloody Marys and therefore the addition of clam chews to them does not make them sound any more appealing.
But you know, if that's the sort of thing you like, you go for it.
Ye
I'm never really sure that I like my cocktails to resemble soup.
I mean I'm very happy to have people throw vodka into my soup though.
So I'd be very up for a kind of chilled clam and tomato.
soup with vodka in it, which does sound like what you were having.
Um it I mean I think that cocktails involving clamato juice are very good.
I also love a Michelada and we had some very good Micheladas while we were in the United States as well.
What's a Michelada?
A Michelada is a Mexican cocktail.
It is um beer.
uh and clamato and lime juice and then a chili lime rim oh and some chili sauce like whole sauce they're good they're very good
I first had one in Newcastle because there is a Mexican restaurant here that does them and I was like, well it's Dia de los Muertos so I should probably like do as the Mexicans do.
And then I was like, oh, this is real good though.
I'm gonna start again.
We discovered that the other person who voted for Mike Scott's house uh was Malcolm Hutchison.
Thank you very much, Malcolm.
Um
You've probably never been to Mike Scott's house either, 'cause it is funnier if you've been there, I think.
Look, I voted for Brisbane and I've never been to Brisbane, so
Don't say this is a drawback.
Liz, you did that while I was drinking coffee and I nearly had a shit shit shit shit shit incident.
Uh-uh
I mean it's quite good, especially as as noted last time, I didn't manage to actually vote for Brisbane.
No, that's fair, that is fair.
Yes, okay, so we've all voted for places we've never been, but Mike's house is very simple.
I would like to do Trish Matson.
Um Trish wrote in about our Hugo Awards saying that my proposal about fan artist, I talked about art culture being lost when fanzine stopped doing art.
And she says that my proposal does not do much to remedy that.
And Yeah, no, that's true.
I mean that's one of the reasons why I dithered and I can't remember if this ended up in the e edit, but I did dither about going for
um best fan art instead of best fan artist.
We probably need to do an episode on fan art at some point because I do have thoughts on it, but it's fair.
And then Trish also says it was nice to meet me and Espania at the Fox Skulk.
And I believe we are using a photo from the Fox Skulk as our episode art this episode, Trish.
So um BS, lovely to meet you two.
And she mentions that she played the inconceivable game show with me, and that will be a podcast
at some point on the internet that you can listen to listeners so I will I will plug that again when it's available.
Uh we heard from DC on Blue Sky.
uh who says, abused by your difficulties, not saying octothorp when you should be saying octocon.
I was having the same trouble listening.
Every time you say octo, my brain went to Thorp.
So I think this will be our new uh call and response during live podcasts.
I think this is going to be a special So
issue for next episode when we will be live from OctoCon where we are online guests.
We will put a we are plugging OctoCon right now and we will put a link in the show notes to where you can buy your online tickets to come and see us
Yes.
It will be a regular podcast, but some t you know, in our next episode, but as ever
When it's our regular podcast, it will be lightly edited.
So if you want to hear the non-lightly edited version, you do have to be an OctoCon member.
Yes.
All the super special gossip that we keep only for our in-person uh listeners.
Or online.
You know, same kind of thing.
No, there's none of that.
It's just nonsense, guys.
There may occasionally be bits that we then decide to cut for reasons of taste and discretion.
Yes, it's much more likely to be taste and discretion than got it, really.
I'd I'd say it's about fifty fifty.
Anyway, come to OctoCon i even if you can't make it in person in Cork, which none of us can.
It will be fun online and we will be hanging around and doing other stuff.
And I'll be attempting to make tiny crocheted octopuses, octopi, octopodies.
I I looked at the programme and I was like, the programme item I really want to be on is the one about indie games, and I
I'm on that game.
I I am on that item, and so is John.
Yes.
Which is probably not a big surprise.
But we probably have different things to say about indie games, so I think that will be good.
Yes.
And then we're on a there's a kind of meet the podcasters thing as well that you can come and see us on.
What are the rest of you doing at OctoCon?
That's a great question.
John is on a panel that I would like to go to.
But it's at like midnight, so I might not.
I I'm just doing those two things.
Uh partly because OctoCon is taking place in, you know, understandably in the uh Cork time zone and I am not in the Cork time zone.
Yes.
To the listeners, we are doing a live at at OctoCon, as we stress it.
If you do have anything, a burning question you want us to answer on OctoCon.
Live, then let us know in the next week before we record it.
Yes.
We shall put a link to the programme in the show notes, listeners.
I won't link to each of our specific like profiles because you can just you can just look those up yourselves.
And presumably cork time is that point in the early afternoon when you open your first bottle of wine.
We heard from Steve by email.
And this was a while ago, so sorry we haven't read your letter out yet.
Steve, it's been the summer of fun.
I think this is a good place to say that we have
There are a bunch of letters we're not going to get round to today and we really appreciate all your letters.
And Steve says
At the age of 57, I have decided to attend my first SF convention.
Good choice, Steve.
And he has opted for the relatively local to him option of BristolCon.
He is male, he likes a pint and he is socially competent.
Do you have any suggested behaviours, do's, don'ts, attitudes or expectations for a first-timer
If you have any of the above that is specific to BristolCon, that will be amazing.
P.
S.
It may seem odd that someone who's never been to a con should listen to a podcast that's so obsessed with them.
I think I found you when you won your Hugo.
It does I mean, yes, I see what you mean, Steve, but also I think we're trying to, you know, we're trying to be a port of call for people who haven't been to cons who might want to dip their toe in.
So um
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Yeah.
We I I've met multiple people over the last few years who have come to their first convention because of Octathop, so you're not alone in that.
I don't know if there are any who've come to a second convention.
Yeah, so do we have any suggestions?
So first off, I don't think any of us have been to Bristolcom.
Yeah, no, I haven't.
I have.
Oh, Liz has.
Aha, Liz has been to BristolCon.
Yeah, so I mean I have been to Bristol Con for a good few years on account of it used to be
Like an hour away on the train and now it's many more.
Um but yes, I think Bristol Cont is a pretty good first con actually, because it's relatively small, it's relatively compact, but I think it is sort of like
a mini version of the comms I like.
So it is, you know, it's got program items, it's got some dealers' rooms, it's got some hanging around in the bar, it's got a quiz, etc.
And because it's relatively small, I mean it it will have a lot of people who know each other, but not enough that it feels like a very insular I am in the middle of a bunch of people who already know each other, what do I do kind of feeling.
I think it is a uh
friendly one as well.
So I think first off good good choice of first com.
Um it's also I don't know where it's out now, but it used to be like pretty central to Bristol.
So if it all gets a bit too much you could run away and go and have a you know mooch around Bristol as well.
It's held at the Hilton Doubletree in Bristol.
Yeah, I think that's where it was when I was going.
Good choice.
Doubletrees are great hotels.
Yeah.
I mean the the bit I fall over on, and this is generally true, is I am a terrible networker.
slash meter of people.
And so I don't have particularly specific tips for that.
Except if there's a quiz, it can sometimes be good to
go along and try and like join up with a bunch of people who are also looking for a quiz team because there's nothing that bonds people like, you know, beating your opponents at trivia.
Yes.
I don't know if they have other items on the program which are specifically for people who have are new to the com.
Sometimes they do, sometimes they don't, especially if they are
smaller ones, but those can be very good as well.
Yeah, I think it's just sees like find the opportunities to chat to people.
Yeah.
And the dealer's room can be quite a good one.
I've had some nice chats
Like with the dealers, but you do have to then be aware that they might have to stop chatting to you because they want to sell something to someone.
Yes.
But I think if you've got like
a bit of awareness of social cues, then you will pick that up pretty quickly.
Yeah.
I think as Steve said he's socially competent, which is fantastic, then
your general networking skills will come in handy here.
But also, despite the fact that it looks like everyone knows each other and they're all having animated conversations that you're not part of
That's not actually the case and also a lot of those animated conversations you would be very welcome in.
So the normal
networking skill of just hanging around fringes of conversations and finding a point to join in does work perfectly well at conventions, as does
turning to the wallflower next to you and smiling brightly and saying, Are you having a night you know, what's going on here?
Are you enjoying yourself?
And just the normal entrance into conversation.
But I am somebody who does not have problems meeting new people at things.
So
There's a sort of standard set of rules about making sure you get enough sleep and eat enough and Th
Don't worry too much about the fact that you can't do everything at conventions because you can never do everything at conventions.
Although I think BristolCon has like a maybe two track program, so you can see quite a lot of stuff.
I do find like striking up conversations with people next to you at the bar works pretty well.
What Liz said is good.
Um I think Bristol Con uh is a great uh choice for a first convention.
My other thing is
So one of the things I've been trying to do more at conventions is going out for dinner with friends to like, you know, actually have some sit-down time.
Because you've got to eat and you might as well eat with people you wanna talk to.
That's harder when you're a first timer.
Um, but like, I don't know.
I I don't know what the BristolCon oove is like, but I would maybe uh this is incoherent.
Ah sharp.
W has never stopped you before, John.
I mean you're right.
I think that tryna if you see a group who look like they're going for dinner and you've you know you've been chatting with them and can can tag along, that is a great way to meet a bunch of people and
you know, have a proper sit-down with them.
Yes.
Yeah, I guess I f I find all this tricky and I mean I find it a lot easier if I have like one good chum at least who is there at the com.
It's yes, it's definitely easier if you already know one person, but like I think BristolCon it is easy to get to know people.
I wouldn't let that stop you, Steve.
If there are any listeners, who are going to Bristol Con?
Then keep an out for Steve.
And he might chat to you.
Or maybe I was gonna say he might buy you a pint, but that's a bit unfair to put your
But I was gonna say, if you're a regular and you're listening to this podcast, please take Steve under under your your wing if if he's looking a bit lost.
Yes.
Yeah.
Um we we need to have the uh the Steve Support Network.
Uh listeners, please form uh please form a phalanx.
Is this any relation to the MOP Protection Committee, Jod?
Uh very closely related sibling organizations.
We need like a listener bat signal of some kind.
Gonna say two more things, which is firstly, I think BristolCon is exactly the right convention um to start with, mainly because Bristol is great.
So if you hate the convention, Bristol is so good.
Uh and on that topic, uh the left-handed giants brewery, if you do find that you want to leave the convention and do anything else
Uh then go have a pint at left-handed giant.
I mean, I'm assuming if you're semi-local to Bristol, you already know this, Steve, but I would be remiss in not mentioning it in case you didn't.
And that's just how it works.
Like sometimes you might be like, okay, I'm enjoying this, but you know, socializing with a bunch of new people is hard work.
Maybe it's not if you're Alison, but it is if you're me.
Sometimes I just want to have a breather and maybe go and have a nice pint or a cup of tea or something.
And Bristol has many places to do that.
It's not like you're at some hotel where you are twelve miles away from civilization.
It is a nice spot for that.
Hope you have a nice time, Steve.
Please write back and tell us which of our tips were good and which of our tips are a load of uh useless nonsense
Yes, that's that would actually be very good.
R writing in to critique our advice after trying to deploy it.
Yeah, because I haven't actually used this advice for some time.
No.
I I remember another classic piece of advice which is if you're going to a panel and everyone is after the panel animatedly talking about the contents of the panel, falling in with a group of those people and ending up in the bar talking animatedly about the contents of the panel.
is a great way to make friends.
Yes indeed.
It was just such a long time ago.
Do we want to move on to topics?
So one of the pieces of news we got, which was just literally just a press release, but I loved it so I wanted it to mention it, is that
The University of Liverpool's Science Fiction Collection, which many of us will know as what was the Foundation's Science Fiction Collection, though it has expanded considerably since then.
has now been awarded designated status by Arts Council England, recognising its outstanding national and international significance, which is fantastic news.
It is a really important resource for anybody doing science fiction research and the librarian is extremely helpful if you have queries and write in.
And it's great.
So this is a amazing news and we're very happy for them.
And hopefully that will op unlock funding.
Unlocking funding is always the
backstory behind these things, isn't it?
And it's the largest science fiction library in Europe.
Yes.
I've never been.
Can you go?
Uh you need to make an appointment.
It's a special collection, right?
So you it like any
special collection.
You say I am interested in researching such and such and I believe you have relevant papers and can I come along and see them.
When I was on my TAF trip
I stayed with Catherine Crockett and Colin Hines in in Toronto and Toronto Public Library has the Merrill collection of science fiction, speculation and fantasy.
And that is open to the public and you can just go and have a look at it.
And it would be nice if that was true of this one true too.
And I know that that is a a a big ask, but I really like that the Merrill Collection is just a collection in a library and you can go and browse.
That's really nice.
So if your anyone's ever in Toronto, I highly recommend doing that.
'Cause I I don't have a professional reason to go and research the one in Liverpool, so I will never ever see it.
And that is a bit sad.
I you don't need a professional reason, you just need a reason.
Well, I mean, but what is the reason?
Just want to have a natter
I think the thing is if you make people write and say, what's my reason for doing this, people will self-exclude, and that is a bit of a shame.
It would be better to have a way of seeing it that did not require people to write a reason.
Prior appointments, so you just you do need to let them know you're coming.
But that's probably all you need to do.
There is a science fiction hub though, and if you which has uh quite a lot of information about what's there, including the papers of
Brian Alder, Stephen Baxter, John Brunner, Ramsey Campbell, Ellen Datlow, Colin Greenland, Eric Frank Russell, and many, many, many other things.
And so I think you could most people could just see from that link some very interesting things and go, ooh, I'd be interested in seeing that.
And then you just need to write them an email.
But also also guys, consider having an open day.
For all I know they may do that.
Yeah, that would be really interesting.
I mean I suspect it's just like it's a collection which is not in an area which is habitually open to the public and therefore you do have to make an appointment so you can sign in and all that kind of stuff, right?
A lot of the stuff's in stacks of course, so Oh they have to pull the boxes out.
I use I used to volunteer when I lived in Chester I used to volunteer periodically at the University of Liverpool in with that collection, um, you know, helping with cataloguing and
Which ca at the time was very much oh we've got this very musty box of something, what's in it.
And I think that's probably quite a lot better now.
It's a long time ago.
So
There was a very interesting article on the Ancillary Review of Books by Cameron Conselman, an academic who had gone to look at some collections
in a l uh an archive in the US which is to go and look at like the Joanna Russ papers and that also in the set of the Joanna Russ papers uh he ends up going and looking
in the like looking as well in the papers of like uh Chip Delaney and looking in the pages of like various other archives to see how it interlinks with
Joanna Russ's archive and is really interesting about the sort of stuff you can do only do by going and looking at like all these letters that people wrote to each other which have been beautifully archived.
I think that's really interesting and I don't necessarily feel I want to go and look at the actual paper bits but I would like to see more kind of like look at this great work someone did
with this lovely archive that has been awarded special status.
That's the kind of thing I would see.
And I will put a link to that article in the show notes, consequently.
Noise.
And also makes you think you can't won't be able to do a lot of this stuff because a lot of people's correspondence is not going to be in archives because it's no longer a bunch of letters.
I I think the website's kinda great.
Um so for each of the archives it's got a page about them that says quite a lot more about what's in it and has a finding aid so that you can find stuff you might be interested in
The other thing I would say, tangentially linking off this, is that I went to a programme item at LACOM, which was about archiving and specifically about the archiving of
um African SF and a database about kind of cataloguing uh fiction uh from Africa, uh which featured
Among others, uh former science fiction librarian of the Liverpool Library, Phoenix Alexander, and it was really interesting.
And I will again link to that if you are an LACOM member, you can go and
Go and watch.
It was also on a really weird time for LA, so I got to enjoy it.
But congratulations to the collection.
What?
After all that, yeah.
Thumbs up.
Some stuff on LA Con
I wanted to be a bit more coherent.
Maybe when John was like, No, it it's fine, I can podcast.
I'll do it very early in the morning from inside inside the bathroom.
It'll be fine.
Ma maybe we should not try and podcast right after.
Well comes.
Is that what I'm saying?
Maybe.
Maybe not at nine AM.
Perhaps not.
Um all right.
Tell us more about LA Con then, John.
Yes.
Yeah, so LA Con five was the seventh World Science Fiction Convention to be held in the Los Angeles area.
There has previously been
Others, one of which was actually held in LA, I believe.
Well the others all in Anaheim.
Which is not in Los Angeles.
And it's all very confusing.
From from this far away, everything looks like Los Angeles.
Anaheim is the Croydon of the Los Angeles region.
I really want to go to Croydon Disneyland, that would be great.
Um that was didn't Banksy do that?
He didn't do it in Croydon.
Did he not do it in Croydon?
Dismaland.
No, it was on the seaside somewhere, wasn't it?
Western Supermare.
Almost indistinguishable from Croydon.
Crydenites don't write entlees.
It was good.
Um and I wanted to talk a little bit about it.
So basically
Most of the time, I think the things that compromise a convention are the program, the exhibits
The dealers and the art show, the games, the socializing, and the convention talking to people.
Those are the six things that comprise a convention.
What do you reckon?
I can't remember the first one now.
Onliney stuff?
I don't know.
I don't think I'm trying to create a dichotomy between the physical and the online
The money.
The m the money?
Oh yeah, the Yeah.
And whether they make it or lose it or how how effectively they manage their finances
The the the fat wards of cash that are transferred between authors and editors in the shady backrooms of the convention?
No no no no no no no no no.
They're just can they actually make the sums add up or not?
That's true, 'cause you could have a really great con that ends up losing like fifty thousand dollars and that would probably compromise my enjoyment of it.
One hundred percent.
I was gonna say can we have a metric of duckishness?
Duckishness?
Yeah, and I think I stole this from Fran.
Basically, 'cause a con is like a duck paddling, paddling, paddling away
But then on the surface it glides.
Oh right, yeah.
So I would like to know how much can you see the legs flapping?
Okay, that's a great question.
I think that varied for different aspects of the convention, but we can definitely discuss the duckishness of the different parts as we go through.
It's it's one it's one aspect of the con
I think in general the programme went very well.
I think the point at which the program displayed its flapping was not.
primarily to do with the program itself, it was primarily to do with the the tech setup in the ACC, which we did talk about last episode.
But I definitely think
Like I said, you're building the track as the train's leaving the station.
The duckishness was more towards gliding as the convention went on.
And by the end of the convention everything seemed to be running very smoothly.
So that was good.
I think the duckishness in terms of the games rooms, I think that was fine.
Like we were still setting up the games room a little bit later than we wanted to open on the first day.
mainly because turns out that putting thirteen hundred board games on shelves takes more than a couple of hours.
Um which in hindsight makes sense.
I mean I guess if you
If you're trying to do it in an organized way, probably, but I mean I but I could chuck thirty underboard games onto shelves.
They were they were um I would call them I was gonna say charity shop alphabetical.
But actually they were more alphabetical than that.
It was quite organized.
It was good.
But I think that was good.
Um the dealers and our show seemed very smooth to me, like I didn't see any setup qualms.
in those uh regions.
Exhibits were quite ducky.
Duckish?
I like learning new terminology, but I'm always worried I'm using it wrong.
But basically I mentioned last time like the not all of the guests exhibits were ready by like the Saturday morning, which was day three.
And it wasn't exhibits who actually fixed that.
But
If I was gonna rank divisions in competence order, exhibits would be quite close to the bottom.
Which sorry exhibits if you're listening, but you gotta have your exhibits ready on day one.
That's just I don't understand how any vision I don't understand how a division head for exhibits could look at an empty d exhibit on day two and think, that's fine.
It's just it's genuinely completely baffling to me.
I don't understand the person who could do that.
I think it is okay to have some exhibits which are gonna come in for part of the convention or come in later.
With plans, yeah.
Oh yeah, if it's planned, yes.
No, that's fair.
If you've planned like these people are available on days two and three and they're gonna set up for days two and three, that's different.
It's if the exhibit's supposed to be there on day one and it's still not there on day three, and you're just like, this is probably fine, what are you doing?
Especially when you're in charge of providing the exhibit.
The exhibits were generally quite good
The ones that were there that I saw.
There was a DeLorean and the Tiki Dalek and other sort of, you know, features of WorldCom.
And the dealers and art show were co-located with the exhibits in the ACC convention center.
Uh and the dealers were very good.
Um not a single shop selling games.
Found that very strange.
Lots of self-published authors.
And some places selling like game adjacent stuff, like notebooks or dice or stickers.
Um, but nowhere selling kind of
board games or TTR.
There was one stall selling TTRPGs that one of their authors had done based on some books they had written, which was the Space Wizard Stand.
But yeah, I was I was surprised by I was surprised by how focused the dealers were on books.
I mean there's lots of reasons why you might not have dealers who have games ranging from
No local dealers, don't want to go to the effort of bringing in huge heavy stock and so on, or maybe just they have dealers who know that they don't tend to sell that many games at kind of west coast
Well, cons.
Like it's a it's a thing to look at, but you might just be sort of stuck.
It's probably true that you're less likely to get games retailers flying from all over the LA to bring games because you'll write games are heavy.
And I guess this might be one of the pitfalls of 'cause there hasn't been an LA convention, uh, WorldConf for twenty years.
And so I guess if you don't have one every ten years, you might lose some of those relationships here and there.
The art show was great.
I did not win the Virginal Finlay original art I bid on.
Surprisingly.
It went for $300 and I did not bid $300 on it.
Which does seem like a fair price.
But basically someone had uh someone had passed and their collection was in the R show and like they had a bunch of virtual Finlay originals in their collection and I was like, What?
That's cool.
Um but the R Show was generally really good.
Um had lots of really good art in it.
WorldCon art shows do tend to be great.
I remember the Luncon 3 art show was amazing.
I loved that art show.
Yeah I I uh I bought a very expensive piece of art in the Longcon Three Art Show and a few months ago we actually put it on the wall.
Nice.
Um only only twelve years afterwards.
Good.
What was it?
What is it?
It's uh it's a fangorn.
If you come to my house it is hanging over my fireplace.
Oh, very nice.
Fangorn's great.
Uh it's fantastic.
Yes.
Fantastic bit of art.
So that was the kind of the bits of the convention, which are the bits the convention can control, I guess.
And the other thing is the
Hugo ceremony, um which I think was a bit duckish in places, but I don't think it was more duckish than most other WorldCon Hugo Award ceremonies.
No, I mean they're just super heavily scrutinized and complicatedly complicated for tech and usually you don't have the auditorium for that long and you know, so on and so forth
You know, but it's a thing everyone tries to get right 'cause the th one thing that non-world con attendees might tune in and watch.
Yes.
And yeah, I think had some seams showing, but I think it was a solid one.
But I think in general the convention was not unreasonably duckish.
Yeah, and I mean I've never been to Anaheim and I know it's not LA.
No.
But it sounds like it is not a bad place to hold a con.
It's a great place to hold a con, as long as you don't want to be able to do any tourism in Los Angeles while you're there.
Yeah.
Because it is sufficiently far from LA that it would not really be plausible.
I mean, if you've got a car it's only like a forty minute drive.
Um but like if you don't have a car, it is it is non-trivial to get to downtown LA from Anaheim.
Um or no
It's easy, it just takes a long time.
But I feel I feel that's a bit like Longcon in that you you can go out and do touristy stuff in central London.
It's just you will have to spend a bit of time.
I guess there is public transport at least.
Yeah.
But it was not like a convenient thing where you can just pop out and go to a museum for a couple of hours.
It was a bit more of an effort.
And I guess as long as everyone knows ahead of time and is not expecting you to be right in LA, get away with it
Yeah?
Yeah, I think that's fair.
Well no Aloheim itself is a nice city, so we went out for tiki drinks at a place called Strongwater, which is very lovely.
Obviously you've also got downtown Disney which has a lot of things in it um and Disneyland itself.
And there's like various restaurants and bars dotted about.
Um so you know it's not there's stuff to do there, which I think helps a lot.
Ob
Um in that sense it's way better than Lung Con because like
the Docklands has less than Anaheim does.
But it's also true that like to get to Anaheim or to get to LA on public transport is possible, but like
You take the Metrolink, which is on the Amtrak rail, and they run once an hour and they stop at like eight.
So it's harder to do.
Um
But yeah.
I mean it is straightforward to get two central London from Docklands.
And there are some things in Docklands, maybe slightly more than there were in twenty fourteen.
Yeah, but there's not like Anoheim has like five breweries.
But
Docklands doesn't have five breweries.
Unlike Anoheim has Disneyland, the Dockless doesn't have Disneyland, like etc.
So like it is I mean which reflects the fact that Anaheim is harder to get to if if it was easier to get to LA, Anaheim would have less stuff.
Um so it's not a criticism or a compliment, it's just like
But the food the social scene was great and the thing I like most about American World Cons is the social scene.
I've mentioned this on podcast before, but like
Like the LA Con social scene was very, very good even for an American WorldCon.
So like the the parties and stuff were great and um and I had a lot of fun at them and you know, a variety of good food and drink, etc.
Not much costuming.
Didn't see many costumes at LA Com.
But I didn't go to the masquerade to be fair.
But like there wasn't much people wandering around in costume that I saw.
Yeah, I don't know what you can do to encourage that.
Or if you just you know, it is what it is.
Well and I think also part of the thing is that LA has enough local area conventions that if you are into costuming you might choose to go to a different one anyway.
I do think in general so it was a smaller World Con than they were expecting, I think largely because of the economic climate.
and the um political climate in the US at the moment.
I
So I can't remember the exact numbers, but it was something like they had 8,500 members of which 4,200 were in person, which is small.
Especially compared to the last LA Con, which I think was like 10,000.
Enormous.
Yeah.
Oh no, sorry.
The last LA Con was only 5,738.
But the last so the last LA con was five thousand seven hundred and thirty eight, which is not as many as we're getting at modern world cons, but was significantly more than the Glasgow WorldCon that it
followed.
So it had about uh 1,500 members more.
So the Glasgow WorldCon in 2005 was 4,100 members and the LA
WorldCom was five thousand seven hundred and if you applied the same maths compared to Glasgow 2024, you'd have been expecting like eight or nine thousand.
but instead they got four thousand five hundred, which was less than I mean, it was a thousand less than Seattle.
I was not really paying attention to this at the time, but as I recall Glasgow two thousand and five, like the exchange rate really uh screwed up.
Travel from the US?
Ah, okay.
I think it was when like there was like some ludicrous exchange rate between the pound and the dollar that suddenly made it very expensive.
Yes, it was great for people on our our side of things who wanted to go to the US.
Yes.
Cause it was two dollars to the pound.
It was glorious.
You kinda have to budget a lot of the time based on what you think you're gonna get and have realistic upper you know upper expectations and lower expectations and so on, but it is very hard to predict when some completely out of control thing will happen and
Doom you.
Not that I think LA Con was doomed, but I suspect if they'd had like uh six thousand people on site rather than four thousand, it would have given a lot more kind of budgetary wiggle room
Yeah, yeah, a hundred percent and I think they were expecting it to be larger than it was.
Yeah, I don't know why Seattle had more members.
But I d I d I mean, you know, the war in Iran has made flight prices go up even more and there's been a bunch of stuff like that.
Ye
So yeah, I think it was tricky.
Yeah, the the Seattle WorldCon was in Seattle this time, wasn't it?
Yeah.
And I don't think I think that is does have an effect on people's cho welcome choices.
Maybe.
I mean I don't I don't disagree that it does.
But I would be surprised if I think there are people who would rather go to LA than Seattle, especially 'cause of Disney, but also like
California is a tourist destination and LA has things like Hollywood in it.
So I don't think it's quite as easy as well no one wants to go to LA.
Yeah, but that might be, you know, the people who can go do a substantial trip from, you know, the UK or whatever, who were not
now not going because they don't want to do a substantial trip to the US at all.
So that kind of Yeah.
But that will have affected Seattle as well.
Yeah, that's kind of what I mean.
I I can't Seattle is like nice, but like and I like Seattle a lot.
Um but I do think that y like I say, like LA Con was like right next to Disney and I suspect that has a big effect on people wanting to go.
Like I know um there are a lot of people from the con who went to Disney either before or after or during the convention.
Um so I'd be surprised if like uh Seattle's just inherently more tourist attractive, but maybe I'm wrong.
I don't know.
I actually suspect a more coherent um reason might be that Seattle had Martha Wells as a guest of honour and Martha Wells is incredibly popular.
Oh yeah.
What would be actually some nice data to have is to survey people and say, like, what does influence your choice of whether to go to a WorldCon or not?
Because I think we have lots of things that we suspect are influences on whether people go to WorldCon or not, but I don't think we know like which ones are a factor for the most people.
Like, is the guest of honour actually a factor for 20%, 50%, 90%?
I am not sure.
So it would be lovely if we actually had some numbers on that.
Yep, I agree.
I'm not volunteering to collect them anytime soon, but you know.
Yes, I I bet people don't actually know why they make these decisions.
They could say why they think they made the decision.
Yeah.
I think having some data is better than no data in almost all circumstances.
Um but also I absolutely know why I went to LA and not Seattle.
Cool.
You have relatives locally, don't you?
Hispania has family that live in Santa Monica.
LA has burritos.
Generally speaking, if you ask me to rank the places in the US I'd rather go to, California is always at the top of the list.
'Cause California is great.
So if you run an uh an American convention in California, that is the one I'm most likely to go to.
But also from my perspective
Seattle, the decision on whether or not to attend Seattle was made three months into Trump's term.
And we had no idea how things were gonna go.
Like there were a lot of scary stories, like it felt very uncertain.
And now making the decision a year after that, it was like, Well, there's been some horror stories, but the level of risk seems not too bad to me, so I am gonna
I'm think I'm okay with that level of risk.
Yes, for you with your with your California family and so on, yes.
I think that surprise it surprises me that Seattle was bigger.
But I wonder whether it's because people had made up their mind to go to Seattle before Trump came in.
And then it's difficult to undo that if you've already booked the flights, for instance.
I think it's that I think it's probably just economic pressure.
Yes.
I mean I think I th yeah, I I strongly suspect the answer is people have less money for holidays and therefore they didn't go on holiday.
I think that's probably by far the biggest factor in determining when whether any convention does well, um, because conventions are a luxury item.
Especially world cons.
Especially world cons on different continents.
But yeah, it would be it would be great at some point to know kinda we can speculate and we know things that are factors and so on, but I mean
I'm thinking of the you know, the big tourist operations know exactly how much this is affecting them because they survey everyone so so much.
And just some basic info that covers multiple years, so we get kind of a cross section of
You know, maybe people who have been or go occasionally versus the ones who go every year and, you know, what what should you be focusing on?
And is there a group of people who will just come to any con that you hold in California?
Wherever you hold in California, for example.
I think I'm rambling now, but you know what I mean.
A hundred percent.
I don't think I have much else on LA Con.
I want to say, like I wanna call out some people I who I think did do great jobs.
So I think that
Tammy Coxson and Emily January did a good job with the Hugos.
Meg McDonald and Helen Montgomery did a great job with programme.
I think it was a really, really good program.
I think those two aspects of it were amazing.
I I toot my own horn, but I think we did a pretty good job on the game side and Petraya Mitchell was instrumental in doing that.
Um so thank you very much to Petraya if she's listening.
Those were I think particular highlights and I think there were
divisions that need to reflect on how it went and maybe make different decisions next time.
And what I'd particularly I'd say is I think virtual division
did not recruit anywhere near enough volunteers.
And while I know LA Con, because of the lower membership numbers, had a general volunteer problem.
um which was evident at certain points.
I do think that if you haven't started writing the scavenger hunt on MIMO Day and then you have to get
the area head of gaming who you see walking past in a corridor to sit down and do it for you because you haven't recruited anyone to do it and if he hadn't done that it wouldn't have happened.
That's the point at which you haven't recruited enough staff.
And you need to think about that.
I mean that's that's the point at which you don't bother with having a scavenger hunt, in my opinion.
It's not worth the people points.
I mean, you might think that, yes, but there was a scavenger hunt channel in the Discord, Liz.
So it's like, yes, there is also a thing where it's like if you clearly haven't recruited someone to do the scavenger hunt
consider not doing the scavenger hunt.
But I think what would have actually happened is the division head would have done the scavenger hunt and the division head already had enough to do.
So that would have been a terrible idea.
I am gonna shout out because I was doing A V clipping, which is where you go and take the recording of the program item and like make sure it starts and stops at the right point and stick it in a link on the
guide and what I've been thinking would happen is I would come in in the morning after everyone's gone to sleep and clip a bunch of stuff and what actually would happen is I would come in the morning uh to clip a bunch of stuff
and discover that Eric had clipped everything already.
So thank you to Eric who basically made me redundant.
Who recruited you to do the clipping, Liz?
Someone recruited me to do the clipping.
Um yeah, Meg recruited me to do the clipping.
But I didn't realise I could do the clipping like complete I basically didn't want to do online stuff because it was like, well I'm gonna be asleep all the time.
And then it was like, oh wait, I could do this thing without having to necessarily be in a sensible time zone.
And that worked okay
Yes.
No, and I think I think that's my other point, which is Virtual would had an even worse time of it if Program hadn't basically recruited a people a bunch of people on Virtual's behalf.
behalf, which I think is the other thing virtual needs to reflect on.
Program digging you out of holes cannot be the method by which every division at the world cooperates.
It's not fair to program.
I will say
And I mean this in in a nice way.
I watched some virtual items and I watched some items live and there was a lot of programme and what I couldn't tell because I wasn't on the ground is
None of the ones I watch seem particularly full.
And I don't know if that's because I was watching stuff at weird times.
Or because like
The layout of the building meant you had to have a lot of things happening in medium sized rooms because you don't have giant rooms.
Like I can't tell how much the size of the venue influenced this, but it did seem to me like there were quite a lot of things happening in rooms where
you couldn't really see if there was a a big audience or not.
I'm talking slightly out of school here because I I haven't I don't have any official numbers.
Yeah.
But put it this way, I think they were expecting substantially more people to come than came.
Mm, yeah, okay.
And I think they
Selected their venue at a point where world cons were getting bigger and bigger and bigger.
And I would be surprised if they were not expecting a Glasgow number of attendees and they got half that.
And I think if there had been twice as many people, the program rooms would have felt much more full.
program fulls rooms that feel a bit sparse or you've got the Helsinki problem where program rooms are definitely not too sparse.
Yeah, you don't want a Helsinki problem
Yeah, and so that's hard.
It's really hard.
Yeah, that makes sense.
And uh like to some extent your program has to fit the venue you have.
And just you know, sometimes this is well, we've got a million rooms, so we're gonna fill a million rooms in case we have a million people.
versus we have more ways to rearrange the rooms and so on and can, you know, ad adapt a bit, not quite on the fly, but if you get to six months out, can you
shift how the rooms are arranged and how many people will fit in each one and so on and and and kind of tweak things and sometimes you can and sometimes you just can't.
So yeah, but it's very hard to tell
from the outside.
It's also kinda weird because when you're doing virtual program it's like, I don't know if there's ten thousand people watching this or just me
Yeah, no that's tricky.
I don't think you necessarily want to show people because you don't want people to get sad if it turns out no one's watching live.
But it's sometimes a bit like I wanna see who else is in here.
I can say that the best interactive uh work panel that I moderated was quite full.
I'm not surprised.
Yes.
The one that wasn't streamed.
I think we mentioned it three times now, so you know, hopefully it'll now turn up.
Yeah, no offen no offense to you, John, but I don't think they turned up to watch you
No, they absolutely didn't.
Hundred a hundred percent no.
I I'm gonna say that's what that's what moderating should be about, right?
Yes, the moderator
There okay, so I've got to say something, and this is not unique to LA, but like I am getting a bit fed up with moderators who are not there to moderate.
Like if you want to be on the panel, don't want to moderate the panel.
And like it's fine for moderator to say stuff sometimes, but I was on a cup I was on at least one panel where the moderator talked more than some of the panelists.
And I'm like, that is not.
The moderator should be the person who talks the least out of everyone on the panel.
in general, unless there's a very good reason not to.
There are some exceptions to that, but yes.
I will say I I watched a few items where I think the moderator was way too
involved and in some of those cases I wondered if it's because well some places people don't really read the moderator guidelines or know what the
the the con is expecting because different ones exist uh expect different things of their moderators but there's a few where it felt like someone might have suggested a panel that
they had really strong feelings about and then ended up moderating it, possibly because it didn't have a moderator and it needed one.
And they were way too involved in it to be able to do that and also mod because they couldn't resist like also
giving their opinions on it, which were very interesting, but that's not necessarily what you want from a mod, especially in there a few panels where they were on, you know, subjects which could have got a bit contentious.
And I was a bit like, oh no, I need the moderator to be kind of
Sitting back and assessing this and checking that everyone is happy with it and and so on and it didn't feel like it was being stably moderated.
Yeah, and I think I think that's exactly it.
S
If you've if you've suggested a panel item and you have things you want to say about it, then you probably shouldn't be moderating it.
And like
The um sometimes I suggest panels because I want to hear what other people will say on the thing and then I can moderate it, but sometimes I suggest ones where I have things to say and then I am a bad choice to moderate.
Uh and I think I'm aware enough of which ones are which that I can reasonably make that determination, but I think some people may be less able to.
I think I feel like I'm learning why I never suggest panels.
Is it because you always uh don't realise there's a deadline and miss it?
No, it's because
Generally speaking, if I want to say stuff about it, I just say it on the podcast or in the bar, or to my friends or on Facebook, see also my pick.
Um Yeah, I don't I don't it's not really related to moderating though, that's related to you.
You just want to chat to people in the bar
Oh one hundred percent.
Yeah, I mean Alison in not that fussed about program shocker.
No I
It's complicated, isn't it?
It is complicated, but of the three of us, you like program roughly twelve thousand percent less than Liz.
And like and Liz likes the bar roughly twelve thousand percent less than you.
Put my I'm in the middle.
So this is where we need a survey where I say to people like what do you like more programmer bar.
Yes.
What do you like more program a art show?
What do you like more?
beer or art show, you know.
For for years and years I've been saying, Oh, but of course I go to folk festivals where I just sit solidly in program all the time and now I've
very much noticed like yesterday.
We didn't really go to very many of the ticketed items, so we could just have not paid.
It's one of these festivals that's in the town and we could just have kind of wandered around and done the free stuff.
And then occasionally gone to a ticketed item and paid on the door for that thing rather than having a day ticket.
And I'm like, oh, and because all the free stuff is like sessions and bar-related
affairs and workshops and all the highly interactive stuff and I'm like, oh apparently I revert to type.
Well and also and I think and to be very clear I sometimes worry that when I say that Alison's not as interested in programme it comes across as a criticism.
But like I absolut I absolutely think and this is something I've said
I've said on a Discord recently that the reason to go to a convention is the convening.
Like the whole point is the people there.
Like if if if it wasn't that we'd just do YouTube panels where we'd just get people together for adcoc things.
And that's not what we do.
So that's clearly not the primary reason to do these things.
And so I do think in general, if you are going to pick only one thing to do and just do that, doing the bit where you talk to people is probably the wisest choice or the choice that's like most in keeping with the philosophy of the event.
And like clearly
people have different lines there, but like the reason you go to these things is for the people in general.
I'm not going to just sit in the corner with a book.
Uh a and also I love program that is highly interactive and social and say workshop and structure you know
And where the audience d are it's not so much a d separation between a panel and an audience, but in fact um a highly collaborative thing involving everybody in the room.
And I would like program I would like convention programmes to have a bunch more of that sort of stuff.
And probably I should therefore be suggesting that sort of thing a bit more.
But you know, I'm old now.
Other young people can organise that.
Yeah, when you're running live action video games again, Allison.
Um, when I'm asked, so yeah, no, I think live action video games could do with an update.
I want to make it a proper like make it look more like other sorts of print and play games because it is literally just stuff printed on index cards at the moment, and it could be better.
And it's about twenty years out of date.
So somebody needs to ask me to do that and then I'll run it.
I have a question, which is, I haven't asked you to do that, but that's also because I've got no idea what it is.
Um and it might be that some of our listeners are in the same boat.
So do you Liz Liz and Alison explain to us this concept?
Yeah, I'm pretty I'm being deliberately I'm being deliberately annoying.
Okay, so this is a print and play game called live action video game Sherards is the necessary thing where essentially you have a bunch of cards and you have on the card you have two teams.
You have a bunch of cards and on the cards you have the name of a video game and a single screenshot from that game and then you you break into teams of people of
uh hopefully differing ages because they vary from Star Trek on computer console through to, I don't know, blueprints or something, something fairly new.
And they they operate the entire span of video games and then people have a variety of props like Nerf guns and bull pit balls and beanbags and one team
And and members of a team have to act out that thing for their team to guess.
And I've done it as a kind of family thing at conventions and I've done it as a
A general thing at conventions and actually FunCon too, if you're listening, would you like this?
I should probably write to you.
It feels like a good fit for that convention.
And I haven't done it for a long time.
Yes, it does sound like a good fit for FunCon.
I think one of the things I find
about program is I like a mix of program.
And then one of the reasons I haven't been to FunCon, other than the fact it's in Buxton, is that
I worry that the mix would not be what I want.
But you also said up there like you said something earlier about like oh with the young people can organise it.
I think the problem you're having is that the young people that are fandom currently are quite into serious discussions about stuff.
Oh they're so n they're so serious circle on there so circle there.
Nellish at all, it is an outrage
Um but not all of them.
And so at some point I think what's happening is that the young people are running the program and you're um being annoyed about it.
And so I think if you want to drag the program slightly more towards stuff you like, or even to show the young people
what can be done in programme.
When was the last time you ran this?
Was it a Ploctocon?
I think it was at a Ploctocon.
I know that for Luncon, I obviously didn't have time to run it, but I did take the cards and leave them in the games room and say if anyone fan
Nancy's this and after the convention Esther came round and said and gave it back to me and said, This was amazing.
I had no idea.
I was like, okay, yeah, no, it is amazing.
Because you don't need the point is that once you've got the deck of cards, you don't really need to be doing it as a program item.
You can always
Also just have it in the games room and let people get on with it.
And of course, Luncon had the sorts of tools you need lying around on the village green as well.
I mentioned it because I played it at Ploctacon and I don't think you've done it since.
There is a game on Board Game Geek, a print and play game that can never be published because it
uses so many other people's IP that is nevertheless extremely highly rated.
And I thought the thing about this is that I thought, oh, I should work this up a bit better with a set of rules and
print and play cards that look nice because it could go there.
It could just sit there and and you know, if somebody sees and desists you from a particular game, you just take it out and substitute a similar game.
Yeah.
But you just you you you couldn't ever publish it because it uses so many people's IP, it's too much like hard work.
But but so so I think this could be a preface to that.
And so I could make this happen at Funcon or at EasterCon if EasterCon is listening or at NovaCon.
How's the Novicon committee coming along?
I don't know.
And I have a programme item I've suggested for next year, which is I played a different board game every day of twenty twenty six and I'd like to talk about it.
I believe that they are enthusiastic about that, but I might be wrong.
I believe so, yeah.
Uh obviously I will be in the bar and if you want to know what board games I've played, listeners, come and ask me in the bar.
With reversed rolls.
That also works for me, to be fair.
I don't think anyone listening doubts that it also works for you.
Sorry for the extensive derail there, it's just I remember PlockedCon playing that game and it was great and I went rolling down a hill pretending to be a katamari.
Uh it was plotted it was the last Plocta.
com at the Civil Service College.
So this is i it is even better if you could get some outside space.
Wasn't even the Civil Service College at that point, but anyway
Um, I had a great time.
I rolled down a hill.
Is that Sunningdale Berkshire?
Yeah.
Yeah, so I so I have found the convention program f
for the last time Alison ran this, which was two thousand and nine.
Yes, so that was Plot.
com where we had a Twitter fall where you have Twitter behind the
program in the main programme hall so you can see what people are saying about the con.
It's a bit like we do for Octo Thorpe.
One of the panelists who will we we should probably not name on the
podcast, but it was Lillian, stormed off halfway through the panel and said she was and and was outraged.
And then she went to the pool.
From which she tweeted quite extensively and of course had forgotten that all of those tweets were appearing in the program room in real time.
That's very good.
It is very good.
That was good.
We started with LA Con and we sort of digressed into general thoughts about the philosophy of conventions, but I liked it.
Hopefully listeners did too.
Yeah, and we've bullied Allison into running
So I will offer I will offer live action video games as a game to play at.
And the pro part of the problem is it was probably easier when I had a house full of children's toys.
I fundamentally don't believe you don't still have a house full of children's toys.
I just think they might be under things.
Yeah, I might need to go and find the props basically.
We may not have all the props.
This could actually work very well for decluttering Allison, because you could leave the props at the Eastercon.
Eastercons right in.
So so speaking of interactive programming, I mean we we had a giant we have a giant twister set
so that you can play Trivial Pursuits Twister, which is another highly interactive thing that you can do at conventions.
I would probably buy a more recent copy of Trivial Pursuit in a charity shop if I was doing this now because my Trivial Pursuit is very old.
I've got four copies of five copies of Star Wars Trivial Pursuit if you want to make it science fiction themed.
But I've also got a very old, very terrible science fiction trivia game we found in a shop, which basically is mostly questions about who won Nebula Awards in the 80s.
So if you want if you wanna make it super zircon on the question level, you can absolutely do that.
Just on the matter of
Three hundred and sixty-five board games.
The board game I bought bought at a charity shop yesterday, John, was Star Wars Quirkle, which I had no idea existed.
That is excellent.
If you declutter it, then please consider me
Yeah, well the only copy on eBay at the moment that someone is asking ninety-five pounds for, so if I declutter it it might be in that direction.
I bet that's just because no one else is selling it though.
I think that's right.
I think it's a German game, the in the rules are in German, and there are some copies on German eBay, but it is it is worth a lot more than I paid for it.
But I might keep it cause cause cause Star Wars Quirkle, that's completely nonsense.
I
It's like Star Wars Azul.
Oh god, it looks so shit.
Well it's beautiful.
It's it's beautiful.
Is it though?
It's photographs from the f- Oh, I don't know about this, Alison.
I don't know.
It is a Star Wars product that is
It it's Schmidt, so so Quirkle's a good game.
Oh, quirkly it's a good game.
But obviously s Star Warsing it doesn't add that much unless you require people to make laser noises when you Well yeah.
And I was hoping it might have symbols from the Star Wars universe, not pictures of
of C3PO, so like I don't know.
Yeah, symbols from the Star Wars universe would be better.
Yes.
But also would only work for people like John, whereas I think they were looking for a slightly more general audience.
Shall we two picks?
Now I'm gonna pick Pandemic Legacy Season 1.
And I will warn listeners at this point that this will contain spoilers for Pandemic Legacy Season 1.
Is that the first one?
It is the first one.
Yes.
As as the season one implies.
So season zero is not the first one.
No, season zero was the third one.
They did one, then they did two, then they did zero.
Oh, that is genuinely confusing, yeah.
Um I so I may have to put my fingers in the ear my ears, John.
So when should I start putting my fingers in say Alison put your fingers in your ears now Um
Alright, so we were playing Pandamic Legacy Season 1 with our friends Jim and Sophie, and Jim and Sophie eventually decided it wasn't really a game for them.
And so Ispania and I have been playing just the two of us, but we've been surely two characters each.
And for those who haven't played it, it starts off as regular pandemic, basically, and then eventually things happen.
And the game changes slightly.
And
So there's kind of two, I think there's two twists that I've seen in the game.
I think the first twist is not a big spoiler, and I think the second twist is a big spoiler
So, Alison, are you comfortable with hearing the first twist?
Clearly not.
She taking headphones off.
Okay.
So, listeners, the first twist, which I think might happen in f
February, so the game's played over twelve months, and I think the first twist is either in January or February, but it's super early doors.
Uh the first twist is that one of the diseases F
becomes zombies.
And obviously you can't treat zombies in the same way as you can treat the other diseases, so that changes the complexion of the game somewhat.
And also you get loads of little zombie figures which are adorable.
And that's great.
And as a result, when outbreaks trigger, like cities get more and more panicked because they're worried about the zombies, and you can't have research stations in cities that are panicking.
So you get military bases and the military starts helping you because obviously zombies, so you know you need army bases and things like that.
So we built some military bases because the research stations were all being burned down and we were like, well military bases don't get burned down, so that's good.
There's a bunch of reasons why you might want to build military bases.
And then you get a bunch of powers which are good because they let you deal with the zombies in other ways.
So there's like one upgrade which lets you effectively shoot zombies when you go through cities.
Which is very useful because it means zombies go off the board.
And then in about August or September, this is the second big twist.
So if you don't want the spoilers for the second big twist, stop listening now.
So you find out that the zombie
Virus has been engineered by some shadowy group of people who want to take over the world via military means, and basically all of the things you've been doing with the military have been part of their grand plan to take over the world.
and you feel stupid and complicit and you start because in the game you've noticed things like, well why can't the medic go from military base to military base?
It's because they don't have the dog tag symbol.
And in the kind of fiction of the game that doesn't really make any sense 'cause you're supposed to be on the same team.
But in the game balance sense, it's like, well, it makes sense that only military characters can take military flights.
But then in the sense of this is a military coup, it makes way more sense.
So like it kind of brings the it's a bit like the trick that the good place plays where there are things you forgive in the Goodplace season one because they're sitcom logic.
But they don't really make any sense in the context of the world being heaven.
And then it f it turns out that actually that's all legitimate within the world and it was a trick the were the show played on you by
Pitting your narrative logic against your sitcom logic.
And Pandemic Legacy does the same trick with the ludography logic versus the narrative logic.
And it l seems narratively dissonant and then it brings those threads so that the narrative becomes more diegetic kind of in that point, which I really liked.
I thought it was really, really clever.
But we've been naming every character after people we know who vaguely do that thing.
And so we named our quarantine specialist Liz Batti.
And then we gave Liz the upgrade that means that when when the coup becomes apparent, it's it's the character with that upgrade that betrays you.
So Liz, you betrayed us to the coup.
And
And it was very annoying.
So your card is torn up in the box.
And I was miffed.
That is why it's my pick this week, because Liz has just betrayed us.
I'm sorry that my fictional fictional version um betrayed you in a military coup.
Thank you.
That's all I wanted.
When did this game come out?
Oh, twenty-fifth?
It was a while back, right?
2015 maybe?
Yeah, I mean it's like it's pre the most recent pandemic, isn't it?
Yeah, twenty fifteen.
Does it feel interesting to play it in a sort of uh I've lived through a pandemic since?
Um yes and no.
Obviously the things uh Alison has put her headphones back on, so I will I will avoid spoilers.
from here.
Yeah, I think that's fair enough.
Yeah.
But yeah, the things we were just discussing, there are there are elements of that and and in pandemic you get a thing where if you lose a game your funding level goes up and if you win a game your funding level goes down.
And that does feel quite a lot like the British government's response to COVID.
Um, so like, you know, there are definitely echoes of that.
Um, but yeah, no, it's an 11-year-old game now.
It's interesting because I had been kind of
Going through it thinking, well this is okay, but like I guess it was really revolutionary at the time, but actually I don't think it's quite as good as the hype has made out to be
And then the last couple of games I've been like, oh, this game is doing things that are much cleverer than I realized before I understood.
what's happening, um if that makes sense.
Yeah, I think all I'd say is there there was definitely a period where it seemed like on the back of Pandemic Legacy, legacy games are gonna be the thing, the big thing, and then no
They didn't become the thing.
I think Gloomhaven became the thing, which is not strictly speaking a legacy game.
Is it kind of a legacy game?
Gloomhaven's like a resettable legacy game.
I think, and like I've been playing, um Meg and I have been playing Regicide Legacy, which I'm really enjoying.
Um, I think the problem is that it's actually quite difficult to use
It's quite difficult to make games which work as legacy games.
Like I think it's it's very easy to make games that change as you play them, but at some point you've got to answer the question, well, why is it a legacy game?
Why isn't it just a campaign game?
Because like Alcam Horror the Card Game changes as you play it, but you can completely reset it and go back to the beginning.
Whereas like wh
And a lot of the legacy games I've played have been like, well this isn't really legacy in any meaningful way.
They just don't want you to be able to play it again when you finish.
Whereas Pandemic Legacy genuinely does seem like it would be very difficult to play it in a way that you didn't stick any stickers on things or you didn't
Like it really uses the mechanic very well.
And I think some games have managed to repeat that trick, but I do think it is very difficult.
I understand Ticket to Ride Legacy is good, but I haven't played it.
And obviously the first game to do this was Risk Legacy, which was very popular.
So lots of people cite pandemic
Legacy season one as being the very best legacy game, and I would like to play it at some point, which is why I've had my fingers stuck in my ears.
So resolutely.
I I picked up Zombie Kids Evolution, which is a l z a legacy game for children, or in our case us, in a charity shop the other day.
For a pound.
That'll probably be my next legacy game.
I kind of disapprove in general of games where you have to deface them in order to play them.
But
I mean obviously you've had your money's worth out of an entire ser season of pandemic legacy, yeah.
Oh yeah.
I mean ultimately I don't mind that as long as you go in eyes wide open.
It basically seems to me that the good legacy games are games that Rob Davio has designed.
So Rob Davio designed Risk Legacy.
And then designed, was co-designer on all of the pandemic legacies and was also co-designer on Ticket to Ride Legacy.
And I basically think he understands how to do it well and he invented it.
And everyone else who's trying to do it who isn't him hasn't quite managed.
There's a few counterexamples, but I basically think if his name's on a legacy game, that probably means it's going to be quite good.
And if it's not, that might be a warning.
I will say not all of his games are bangers.
I've also played Betrayal Legacy, which is, I would say, okay.
But I don't know if that's just because I don't like Betrayal very much.
Betrayal at House on the Hill.
Alright, so what else do I pick?
I talked for ages.
Shall you mine?
Yes.
So, uh speaking of trivia games that need you to know like uh Nebula's from the mid-80s, uh not quite that, but uh I have been reading Foreigner by CJ Cherry and also the sequel uh Invader.
So what happened is there is a big uh humble bundle style thing where you can buy like a big, big, big pile of CJ Cherry books for a low, low price, although not in the UK, sorry, people in the UK.
And so I bought like thirty-five books or something.
Um, and then I was like, what now?
So then I went to the uh very excellent for this kind of thing, uh, ancillary review of books
Discord and said, Where should I start?
And I got several possible starting points, and some of them said, Why don't you start with Foreigner?
Which is a series which started in 1994.
Four.
It consists of like twenty three books or something like that.
And we'll possibly never be finished now that Cherry is a tribe.
Anyway, what what it is really good at is
Aliens.
So the the idea here is that um a a human starship that was going off to uh start a human colony ends up off target and ends up with the cumans
coexisting uneasily on a planet with its own alien inhabitants called the Atevi.
And the way the the book the book is mostly taken up with Bren, who is the one human who
is the interpreter to the Atevi.
And so the setup here is you have these aliens who who look humanoid, although they are uh taller and stronger than humans.
And it's all about this interpreter who is the one to know their language and interpret to them.
And crucially, the world they've landed on is at a lower level of technology.
But in order to ever return
to space, the humans are gonna need the inhabitants of the planet and all the resource they control that they've made had a war and made this uneasy treaty with.
They're going to need to kind of bring them up to a different level of technology
So the Bren, the translator, is kind of very much in control of what he tells them and what bits of technology they get.
And it's it's a very close focus on this one person who is ends up very he's super isolated because he's with all these people who
look humanoid that he can communicate with, that he can talk to, but they are in many ways alien and there's a lot of like him trying to understand how the political intriguing is going to work.
in a society which has these almost biological associations or like loyalty to the clan you belong to.
And they also
have a very intuitive understanding of maths.
And a lot of the society is kind of you have to have the harmony mathematically in in society.
And it's like, how do you then try and explain to them, for instance
faster than light travel, which violates these like mathematical rules that they have on the world.
Um and it digs into this a lot because the whole thing is kind of very tight perspective from this one person
who is obviously the the person who's got the best communication with the aliens, but also is very isolated, gets very lonely.
Who can he trust and rely on when he doesn't fit into their like
natural structures of trust and doesn't understand like every action he takes, he has to kind of consider how this is gonna be perceived both
by the humans that he works for and also by the aliens that he lives with.
And I think it's probably one of the more complete kind of portrayals of
alien thinking in a culture who because they look so close to human he has to be reminded constantly that these are not actually humans.
You cannot like rely on them
responding to you in the same way that a human would.
I'm enjoying it so far, with the caveat that because it's all got a very tight perspective from one person, they move pretty slowly
So I've read the first two and I think there's a there's a third one that will kind of cap off this trilogy and then everything is done in kind of further arcs as are trilogies that you can read.
And I'm not sure how many I will get through, but I am enjoying the first one.
Excellent.
I saw that bundle and I was annoyed I couldn't buy it.
Yeah, sorry.
Yeah.
I have just that's that's a shame.
But you know.
Because I think they're actually I don't think they're available as ebooks in the UK that freely, so some of them you can get, but I'm not sure you can just go and like
buy them all for your coba, whatever.
Yes, so because I have a book by Cherry on my list of books I want to read.
But yeah, I seem to remember
thinking that it was like a bit hard to find and I can't I wonder whether that's connected.
I have actually owned Sightine
Which is another classic works for a while and i is currently in use as a laptop stand 'cause it's very fat.
Brilliant.
But that was not in the bundle, so the one I want is Hunter of Worlds.
That was the one I th I think because I would have been asking for
recommendations for linguistic science fiction and I think that was one of the ones that got recommended to me at that point.
But yeah, I I I have it on my eBay watch list because I couldn't find another way of buying it.
Like as far as like I guess I get a secondhand copy of eBay.
Um but maybe that is because the UK rights are weird.
Yeah, I think they might be.
I'm not sure Hunter of Worlds is even in this bundle.
We will put a link in the show notes, listeners, for
people who um well assuming it's is it still going?
It won't even show it to me because I'm in the UK.
Um it is still going but it
We'll just about be going if you're listening now and you go very quickly.
But that sounds good.
Yeah, it was interesting and it's definitely like I've had lots of cherry like recommended at different times and this was definitely like filling a gap.
uh in my reading.
So I would like to um celebrate historical sequential art and talk about the Bayotapestrait, which I went to see on Thursday.
It's at the British Museum at the moment, which I think anyone in Britain who's not been under a rock will probably already know, but other people might not.
Um people were like you need to be careful about lending things to the British Museum because they may not give them back and there has been a kind of exchange of hostages with um the Sutton Hugh helm helmet and the Lewis Chessman going off to France and some other things, clearly.
i as a guarantee of safe return for the tapestry.
Um I wrote about my queuing experience on Facebook and Mike Glyer immediately grabbed it for file seven seventy so you can go and look at it there.
Um the short, the too long don't read.
version of this is that you get about thirty minutes with the tapestry, during which you are continuously exhorted to walk along the tapestry.
And that thirty minutes started an hour and uh an hour and forty minutes after the printed time on our tickets, which we were early for.
So and the the rest of the time is spent in cues in AQ.
Uh and a queue is just broken up into bits.
If you've ever been to a theme park and gone
without special fast pass arrangements to the most popular ride at the busiest time of day, then all of this will be very familiar to you, and it was very familiar to me.
It did not stop people in the queue around us whining quite a lot.
And I I was quite sharp with one of them.
They'd love to sell more.
If they could, they are op they are lighting the tapestry for the most hours in the day that the French will let them, which seems perfectly reasonable to me.
They are giving people a reasonable amount of time with the tapestry.
I think thirty minutes is you'd definitely like to spend longer, but it's probably enough.
So I don't think they could reasonably have done much more.
It's fantastic.
It's amazing.
Go and see it.
It's if you know, if you're around London, um it's really, really good.
They're releasing more tickets next month and it's a bit like Glastonbury but less well organized in terms of getting tickets.
So it is one of the
Fine as well as being an incredibly important um primary source historically, it is an a fantastic bit of sequential art that actually has lots of things to
tell comics artists much later.
So there's there's bits this is a slight spoiler for a thousand year old piece of art, but um th there are bits where 'cause there's borders at the top and bottom of the tapestry as well as the main action and there are bits where the main action
gets so exciting that it um it it encroaches the top and bottom borders in a way that is clearly intended by an an an overall designer who we obviously don't know who that was but was absolutely brilliant in terms of
making the tapestry say what they wanted it to.
I have seen it before 'cause I went to Bayer to see it.
It will be back in Bayer next year.
If in the Bayer Museum, which is not hard to get to from the UK.
Um there aren't big cues, it's not a
major thing.
The French don't think this tapestry is anything like as important as the English do.
Um you know, so next once it's back in its new museum you'll be able to see it without any of this palava for a lot of the money.
You know, a weekend in London is probably more expensive than a weekend in Bayers, so you know, that's one way to see it.
There are copies of this.
There is a fully embroidered copy in the Reading Museum, and you won't have to cue for that either.
It has been slightly badlerized as
There's a very long explanation of why that happened, but there's not that there aren't that many rhubits in the tapestry anyway.
Um and they d I don't think I don't think it's really very important.
Um there is a comet in it.
Um it is the first representation of Halley's comet, which slightly a mate visual representation.
People have been talking about the comet for about twelve hundred years at that point, but it does appear to be the first
picture that we have of it which is very cool.
And yeah, I thought it was absolutely brilliant.
It's beautifully displayed.
Yeah, really enjoyed myself
Um did not enjoy an hour and forty minutes of queuing.
They do have little museum stools for people who need them, including me, that you can carry around with you.
It has ninety-three penises.
Yeah it does.
Or nine I say people argue about one of them.
Some people say it's a scabbard.
Is that a sword in your scabbard or are you just pleased?
to see me.
Yes, the vast majority of penises are horse penises though, and if that's something that you find very exciting, then don't write in.
Ye
Or go and work for the FBI.
That's satire.
Oh yeah, no indeed.
Yeah.
That was the Octothorpe Podcast.
And it's goodbye from me.
It's goodbye from me.
Now, as we sometimes mention, we get emails from people who are selling things.
So we get emails from
uh marketing people being like, here's a new science fiction book, or here's a new science fiction venue in London where you can pretend to be a spaceship, or here's a new board game.
And these are very lovely.
But we know we've arrived in the swim headphone podcast arena, listeners, because we've had our first pitch email from a swim headphone technology person.
in the form of Leonard Whitler who has made an app.
What does the app do, John?
If you
Have a USB-C to USB A adapter and you plug that into your phone and then you plug the headphones into that.
It will show up as a thing on your Files app on your iPhone.
And Leonard has made an app that lets you easily track the podcasts that are on your
uh headphones it will track ones you've listened to and then it will download new ones onto the headphones for you which is a very niche app
Oh no, it's a niche app I want though, I think.
It it does sound like a genuinely useful app.
It does.
Because one main problem with having swim headphones is that you have to plug them into a computer and manually move
files onto it like you know you're in the mid nineties or something and this means you don't have to do that.
However, it's an iPhone app.
So
It is an iPhone app.
I am the Resident Non-Apple device lover, so it is useless to me.
I this went into my spam because if it hadn't gone into my spam, I would already have tried it.
And so here then is this is to say we're plugging your app without having tried it yet, unless John has tried it.
But I will I will try my first app free.
I don't know how much it's gonna cost.
This is one of the reasons why I have not tried it.
I don't know whether to say this on the pod, but basically it's £30 and I was like, that is more money than I want to spend on solving this problem, regrettably.
So I might do £29.
99 one off, um, Leonard.
Let let me have a go and see if it works on my free sync.
But what I have worked out is for my purposes I can use it to listen to
The way I'm using it, I haven't run into this because what I've basically been using it for is episodes of podcasts from Patreon at the moment, which are on Quinn's Quest, and basically he releases like I have like
five seasons of Play to Find Out what to catch up with.
So I've just loaded them all on and I'm working my way through them.
So I think for me it might be a case of just like doing ten at a time anyway.
But like
I don't know.
I might come back to this in the future.
So I am going to replace his his pitch because I think the pitch is great.
Built for the last two minutes before getting in.
Um pick episodes on your phone, sink them to a folder and get in the water.
Android support coming soon, Liz.
Because what happens with me is that
And this will not come as surprise to anyone on uh I like to listen to a particular podcast while swimming and what happens is every time I go swimming, about five minutes before I'm due to leave the house, I go, Oh
Naughty swear word, naughty swear word, naughty swear word.
I have not synced the latest episode of that podcast to my iPhone.
And if I had this app, I could do that on the bus
And that would just make my life a lot better.
Yeah, that's fair.
Yeah, so it i if you wanna use uh if you want to like uh listen to a podcast for th
From this week when you go swimming this week.
I think this is probably a great shout, Leonard.
This is of course functionality that the headphone app ought to have
Built into it.
It is outrageous that it doesn't.
Um, you know, if I'm spending 150 quid on a pair of swim headphones, I ought to be able to sync them to my iPhone.
Oh my goodness.
Well no and and so yeah I've got two criticisms of the shocks, which is firstly the cable they come with is USB A, not USB C, so you can't just plug it into your iPhone, you need to carry a little widget, and that's annoying.
And secondly, I don't understand why the app doesn't let you manage the files on the device.
to to sync to my computer as well because my computer also does not have USB A slots.
Hasn't done for many years.
I have a USB A hub attached to my computer.
I th I think it it does obviously
feel the problem that the manufacturer should be solving and have not and yeah if that is good for you you probably pay twenty five dollars for it.
I probably won't because I just dump a load of podcasts on there every so often and forget about it.
But
I think it does definitely fill a niche and also I'm very excited that someone has marketed what is probably one of the most relevant emails we've ever had to our actual needs.
Yes.
No, that was very good.
Well done, Leonard.
Yeah, this is like a this is a top draw email, Leonard.
Um thank you very much.
Yeah, we should probably write back because he actually emailed us twice because he didn't hear back the first time.
So
We will probably write back and say, um, yeah, no, you're but he may be a regular listener now, or he may just have grabbed the internet for podcasts that mentions swim headphones.
Yeah, I think he's grabbed the internet for swim headphones.
But maybe we are genuinely one of the internet's premier swim headphone podcasts.
That would be very funny.
I haven't been swimming since the emails came in, um, because I've been
uh LA and then at a conference.
So I have not tested it out mostly because I have not been doing much in the way of this.
But I will test out.
We will report back.
Uh Octocon, swim headphone corner live.
The theme music for this episode was Surf Shimmy by Kevin McLeod and Combotech.
com used under a Creative Commons Attribution 4.
0 license.
This podcast will end at the beep.
Beep.